ça se peut pas que ça dure toujours ça
s'peut pas c'est trop fort c'est trop
pure notre amour là ça se peut pas que
ça dure encore ça se peut pas
quand les astres seront morts tout le
tralala ça s'peut pas ya trop de bonheur
ça s'peut pas l'amour le vrai un jour y
meurt il reste pas
on se tient fort la main en marchant sur
des parkings on se dévore des yeux sous
la lune sanguine et on se croit plus
malin et on n'a peur de rien et on se
croit plus malin et on n'a peur de rien
ça s'peut pas ton coeur sans quoi ça
s'peut pas en visant beyer l'apport au
wynn mais pas 16 pts match de phases d
chaucesse peut pas quand je serai fripé
plein d'arthrose rites et tout ça ça se
peut pas
un jour ça s'peut pas pour à l'autre mes
yeux de la main tu m'oublieras on se
tient fort la main en marchant sur des
parkings on se dévore des yeux sous la
lune
sanguine et on se croit l'humeur et on
l'apprend
et on se croit plus malin
et on n'a peur de rien mais ça s'peut
pas qui est plus un jour ça s'peut pas
tout ce bonheur tout cet amour
ralala sasquatch est pas encore à ce
faux pas on les astres ce roman nous de
tout ça ça secoue pas et dit ne m'agace
pas que notre amour aliments y restera
on se tient fort la main en marchant sur
des parkings on soudait boire des yeux
sous les 110
et on se croit m
bon
et on se croit malin et on attend
et on sera plus main et on n'a peur de
rien demandé rien on était alors